[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission consacrée
à la photo avec deux invités que je suis
ravi de recevoir Jean-Pierre Évrard
bonjour vous êtes vous êtes un des
grands photographes français je suis
très heureux d'être que vous venez
plus régional
vous êtes vous êtes photographe aussi
grand spécialiste de la photo et de
l'histoire de la photo et vous allez
faire une exposition à la qui commence à
la fin du mois le 28 février à Épône on
va en parler évidemment
j'avais une question qu'est-ce que c'est
la photo
bien sûr mais ce qui est formidable
c'est l'évolution de cette pratique qui
au départ était réservé aux chimistes ou
peintre qui avait trouvé un nouveau
moyen commercial de
se faire connaître
et puis tout doucement grâce à à des
invasions golf celles de Kodak que je
connais bien
passé une partie de votre vie donc la
pratique est venue courante dans les
familles et mais maintenant avec le
numérique parce que Claude contrairement
à ce que je pense je reconnais certains
mérites
notamment pour l'argentique
de pouvoir tout le monde c'est de la
photo il y a pas de frappe les enfants
personnel
de la photo mais est-ce que justement
est-ce que c'est pas un problème c'est
vrai que c'est vrai que la photo
apendant été longtemps enfin tout le
monde pouvait faire des photos mon frère
il y avait des des vraies photographes
et puis bien sûr des amateurs et
aujourd'hui avec les iPhone avec les
voilà tout le monde fait de la photo
tout le monde fait de la photo tout le
monde fait de la photo d'ailleurs il y a
on se demande même les les paparazzis
par exemple qui existaient autrefois
tous les photographes de presse comme ça
qui prenaient des photos cachées bah il
y en a plus parce que c'est les gens qui
prennent les photos
tout le monde prend des photos mais
est-ce que tout le monde et photographes
ça c'est autre chose ça c'est autre
chose et évident que déjà
en revenir à l'argentique pour faire un
bon photographe il y a aussi la partie
laboratoire souvent qui va derrière ça
demande moi j'ai fait un apprentissage
de deux ans avant de commencer à
travailler pour moi donc maintenant
j'allais dire quelques semaines mais
peut-être quelques mois on commence à
faire de très bons photos de bons
photographes mais avec ce que pour vous
ne devrait pas droit mais le photographe
c'est pas seulement celui qui prend la
photo c'est aussi celui qui la développe
non non quartier Bresson que tout le
monde connaît le développement
si ce que mon cas par exemple on
travaille en photographie pour
disons travailler dans le domaine de
plutôt artistique moi je travaille
plutôt avec des collectionneurs
via la galerie qui me représente qui est
la galerie rouge la galerie rouge
absolument bon
la partie de mon travail à moi personnel
mon travail c'est la prise de vue c'est
indispensable c'est là où est la
photographie le vrai photographe
et il y a la partie laboratoire et une
partie plus technique qui que l'âge
personnellement je développe beaucoup
bien sûr
on peut parce que ça change est-ce que
on peut une photo change quand elle
passe au laboratoire
non qu'est-ce qui se passe
ce qui fait effet ce qui est dans
l'appareil
tout le monde travaille de façon un peu
différente
un photographe qui donne ses photos un
laboratoire lui donne des indications
mais c'est pas lui qui fait mais le
truc le tireur fera les photos en
fonction de ce que j'ai attendu de faire
si on travaille sur ces photos mon
pauvre cas en principe comme j'étais
j'étais beaucoup plus formé au départ
comme technicien plutôt que comme
photographe
avec la marque kodal bien sûr mais oui
je vais faire mettre j'allais dire trois
générations de photographe c'est sûr
bon
quand je fais quand je vois un sujet je
veux photographier parce que ce sujet me
plaît je poste déjà comment je vais le
tirer
ces deux actions parce que contrairement
à la plupart des photographes qui
commencent à faire la photo et après la
faire le tirage après en argentique
maintenant moi j'ai pris le cheval
la carrière différemment c'est à dire
la charrue avant de les vœux au début
avant dans la rue toujours est-il c'est
que moi je commençais d'abord être la
technicien et je reste quand même la
technique a beaucoup d'importance pour
moi Claude quand vous faites des photos
alors moi
si vous voulez j'ai commencé par faire
de l'argentique dans les années
l'argentique c'est quoi c'est le papier
et c'est le papier avec un appareil
photo tout simple qui a des réglages
etc il faut développer dans le noir avec
la lumière rouge contrairement moi je
pense que c'est presque aujourd'hui pour
les gens qui s'intitule photographe
comme Jean-Pierre je trouve que ce
passage par l'argentique permet de
comprendre comment après on va pas
pouvoir travailler en numérique
vous pensez qu'il faut d'abord commencer
par l'argentique même si on passe au
numérique moi je dirais que photographie
ça veut dire en venant du grec photos
lumière graphique écrire avec la lumière
ce que je disais quand je disais
qu'est-ce que c'est la photographie
qu'est-ce que la cartographie nous dit
que par exemple les cris ne nous dit pas
voilà alors c'est une façon de moi je
sais je sais pas très bien écrire si
vous voulez en fait je sais écrire mais
ce que je veux dire je suis pas un pro
de je suis pas littéraire voilà moi ce
que je trouve je m'exprime avec la photo
pour moi une photo doit avoir du sens
parce que effectivement j'habite donc
près du château de Versailles et quand
je vois si vous voulez tous ces gens qui
qui avec leur téléphone appuient sans
savoir ce qu'ils vont prendre mais
surtout qu'est-ce qu'ils en font
derrière parce que moi toute une faute
voilà que deviennent ces photos il y a
il y en a aujourd'hui comme je dis on
est demain de tsunami de photos s'il
vous plaît mais qu'est-ce qu'elles font
les gens moi si vous voulez à partir de
ce de ces photos je prends parfois avec
mon téléphone mais j'ai toujours un
appareil photo dans ma poche ou quelque
chose comme ça je vais je vais essayer
de donner du sens à mes photos et comme
disait Franck corback était un
photographe de mode que peut-être
Jean-Pierre a connu qui est décédé en
photographier ce n'est pas seulement
appuyé sur un bouton c'est à dire que
c'est une part de vous-même de là où
vous trouvez vous allez immortaliser
cette photo qui ne se cet instant précis
ou plus jamais ce temps conviendra c'est
d'ailleurs une fois que vous avez fait
la photo c'est là un autre moment voilà
c'est ça maintenant ou jamais alors moi
je suis passé au numérique mais souvent
je dis si vous voulez beaucoup de gens
ont dit surtout dans la presse dans les
médias on disait que la photo numérique
c'était plus facile que le la photo
argentique je dis c'est faux parce que
déjà il faut maîtriser l'ordinateur il
faut d'abord maîtriser l'appareil photo
et Jean-Pierre quand on lui montre des
appareils photos c'est d'une complexité
notoire Jean-Christophe Béchet disait
moi je rêve d'un appareil photo où on
peut faire trois réglages les vitesses
l'ouverture et la sensibilité des filles
donc voilà c'est comme les claque merci
codage
et puis je aussi que il va falloir après
maîtriser les logiciels et là les
logiciels photos d'une complexité de
notoire mais il y en a un où on retrouve
pratiquement le process que nous
faisions en argentique c'est-à-dire
qu'un argentique on prenait son film on
le mettait sur la grandeur on régler les
le cadrage on régler on faisait des
examens qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui sur
certaines de ces logiciels et puis après
vous maîtriser la chaîne graphique parce
que alors Jean-Pierre un jour parce que
on se voit régulièrement je lui dis je
vais je vais te tirer une photo et
Jean-Pierre m'a dit non Claude tu vas
imprimer une photo donc voilà c'est la
nuance et donc c'est là cibler où il y a
ce tout ce travail qui est assez
complexe et alors maintenant on commence
à trouver des l'intelligence
artificielle qui arrive alors là c'est
peut-être
des robots qui nous photographie le
photographe qu'est-ce qu'il va faire pas
grand chose et pour moi la photo c'est
quelque chose qui est chronophage où on
y passe beaucoup de temps moi je connais
ce que le travail de Jean-Pierre si vous
voulez justement on va on va parler un
peu du travail de Jean-Pierre donc euh
j'avais vous
on parlez de donc de l'argentique enfin
votre façon de travailler et c'est le
noir et blanc aussi
[Musique]
restons sur cette photo là elle est très
intéressante parce qu'au fond il y a
trois photos en une c'est ça c'est ça
dans une dans une image je reviens un
petit peu à ce que tout à l'heure au
sujet des des
amateurs ou tout le monde photographique
mais il y a pas cette connaissance
justement de la composition d'une
photographie
si on prend les grandes peintures de des
grands maîtres de la peinture de siècles
précédents ou actuels il y a toujours
une composition extrêmement précise très
précise lorsque j'ai fait mon
appartisage photo
mon patron à l'époque qui a vu que
j'étais pas tout à fait
idiot m'a dit
j'avais 18 ans 19 ans et
il m'a dit voilà
ça va en sorte depuis un an
maintenant je vais faire une proposition
où tu acceptes et on va faire ensemble
tu refuses tu préfères ton service
militaire et voilà
trois fois par semaine tu arrêtes le
poteau le boulot à 15h et tu vas suivre
les cours aux Beaux-Arts
j'ai dit oui tout de suite
et
c'est mieux de devenir trop fion bien
sûr et
longtemps après quand j'ai vraiment
travaillé en photo parce que j'ai
commencé à travailler pour moi que dans
la à 40 ans avant je travaillais pour
les autres quand même où je faisais de
la formation je me suis rappelé tout ça
tout ce que tout ce que vous avez dit on
verra quelques photos que j'ai ramené ou
une image c'est elle doit être lisible
sans qu'on s'en aperçoit et ça c'est la
composition qui donne ce ce donc est-ce
que c'est est-ce qu'on peut parce que
souvent on est à la photo c'est le cadre
et des cinéastes disent ça aussi
bien sûr toute façon
une bonne photo c'est ce qu'on attendait
si après il faut je serai fouiller pour
faire autre chose bon c'est bien c'est
génial mais ça m'intéresse pas bon
par exemple celle-là on peut s'arrêter
il y a trois scènes différentes alors
disons le mérite que j'ai eu c'est votre
appuyer sur le bouton c'est d'avoir
perçu tout de suite donc je me suis
approché très très très près du petit
garçon qui est au premier plan et
ça se fait une seconde parce que les
trois
sur l'instant bien sûr d'accord
ce qui est important c'est d'avoir perçu
ça immédiatement
par exemple voilà c'est intéressant
parce que
une femme qui est en train de avec son
pilote de de ça c'est où est au fait au
Sénégal au Sénégal
bon
quand tu reconnais là il y a un type
averti on dit très bien c'est pas
uniquement cette femme en train de
travailler
c'est intéressant c'est pas c'est de
garder on va venir à la salle de bain
ce cercle qui a cette composition en
rond c'est ça
j'ai utilisé même les traces sur le
vieux mur
et l'ombre par contre c'est là où
m'avait dit une fois ça cerise sur le
gâteau c'est que j'avais pas perçu du
tout tout ça je l'ai vu
c'est que la lombre que derrière la
femme n'est pas en train de
lancer son pilon dans un vrai saut non
pas dans l'ombre
donc il y a ce mélange c'est incroyable
cette composition cercle et là c'est pas
bien sûr et la photo qui avait tout cet
après on retrouve ça de nouveau ce
cercle qui arrive absolument
ça c'est un petit peu ce que je regrette
chez tous ces
personnes qui font de la photo
ce qu'on appelle la photo souvenir c'est
très très bien mais ne passe pas avoir
derrière qu'est-ce qu'il y a
heureusement
que tout le monde voit pas ça hein
de belles photos vous me direz bien sûr
attends je termine juste là-dessus ce
qui est ce que je dis dans une photo il
y a un premier plan il y a un deuxième
plan et un troisième plan
quand il met des stages pour vous
occupez pas du premier plan il est bon
directement puisque c'est pour ça que
vous faites la photo mais regardez
derrière au deuxième plan voir au
troisième plan et c'est là où attends la
composition le truc et c'est un comme un
puzzle on arrive à mélanger
ce que vous avez exploré il y a donc
l'Afrique il y a le Maroc et vous avez
d'ailleurs écrit un livre qui s'appelle
Maroc terre du cochon lointain alors
terre du cochon lointain
alors c'est un titre qui était sujet par
Patrick
fondateur de directeur français de la
Maison de la Photographie de Marrakech
d'accord et puis je travaille à ces
traitement
faire du cochon lointain c'est donc
alors
ça veut dire Maghreb
et puis alors il y a aussi je sais pas
si on a des photos là mais il y a une
chose
elles sont très belles ces photos parce
que c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose
qui est fascinant c'est le foot
très important pour moi car c'est pas
c'est pas ce que j'étais un passionné de
foot de l'âge de 12 ans que je suis
devenu photographe parce que
[Musique]
au grand désespoir de mon père le foot
va être assez beaucoup plus que les
études ce qui fait que
arrivé à 18h sur les conseils de mes
professeurs
m'a proposé d'aller faire
un stage puis un apprentissage chez un
photographe de province à Cambrai c'est
très très bon photographe qui est assez
connu régionalement et
du coup j'ai arrêté j'ai arrêté le foot
pour la photo
j'ai quand même repris beaucoup plus
tard dans l'équipe de Maurepas ici en
tant que vétérinaire
et cette idée de mais c'est vrai
qu'elles sont elles sont magiques
souvent ces photos dans n'importe où
votre gamin qui qui qui font des buts
avec ce qu'ils ont sous la main qui joue
avec nous c'est magnifique
c'est des ballons qui sont pas des
ballons
donc
voilà sur la joie sur les sur l'enfance
sur le
chercher et je suis aperçu assez
rapidement que le but
était un cadre et que la photo elle se
faisait à l'intérieur de ce cadre
c'est un cette
chanson une idée qu'on poursuit
c'est même une grande joie et justement
je reviens
cette anecdotique mais je suis mon
grand-père avec mon père a un jour
d'honneur et puis moi j'étais vilain
canard qui faisait récupérer
cette médaille
vous avez pensé à 6 papa était là
ça arrive généralement un peu tard pour
que les bonbons
je voudrais juste rajouter une chose
parce que dans Jean-Pierre oublier de
parler donc c'est c'est son esprit aussi
de de
se retrouver des vieilles photos et de
les restaurer il est entre autres le
jour où on lui a remis cette médaille il
a offert à la mairie de Maurepas un
portrait de Éric van Strohen qu'il a
restauré vous savez que
il est enterré à l'intérieur
et il a offert une photo
grand acteur allemand entre les deux
guerres quoi je crois qu'on peut les
situer dans un film de Renoir je crois
donc notamment la photo
ça m'énerve
d'officier allemand avec son chien
et donc je voulais quand même parler de
ça parce que c'est aussi un travail très
important de de Jean-Pierre et quand
vous allez dans son antre cibler vous
avez toutes les boîtes qui sont bien
rangées avec toutes les photos bien bien
préparées donc c'est aussi un travail
très important donc pour Jean-Pierre
parce que c'est pas facile quand on
trouve des vieilles photos elles sont
souvent dans des
à Marrakech
cette photo de
mérite d'être une photo de 1928 ou 26 ou
28 où il est encore assez jeune
40 ans
ça c'est une photo
il y a
40 ans je fouillais les brocantes les
éventueux
et puis je me suis rappelé j'avais cette
photo là et vous allez il faut qu'on
parle de ce qui va se passer épaude du
1er février ou du 28 février pardon au
1er avril la médiath
on a déjà exposé donc à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux un espace de
Coville
on s'était focalisé sur ce que j'appelle
le bord de mer donc Alain et quelqu'un
qui qui a des parents qui étaient
originaires de l'île d'Oléron d'accord
d'où on voit les débarrasses de pêcheurs
si vous voulez qui était qu'on voit à
l'écran donc Alain a beaucoup travaillé
sur ce sujet si vous voulez donc où les
gens les possesseurs de cabanes comme
ils avaient des bateaux quand ils
restaient de la peinture après avoir
repeint le bateau ciblé sincèrement
alors on expose une quarantaine d'images
à peu près donc
la médiathèque pierre Mouroux et vous
votre travail alors c'est vous êtes
plutôt vers l'arcachon non 16 ans alors
moi je suis originaire de Bordeaux donc
j'adore les plages de l'Atlantique si
vous voulez qu'ils sont immenses qui
sont à perte de vue et je me suis sur
cette série je me suis focalisé si vous
voulez surtout c'est blockhauses qui ont
été construits pendant la dernière
guerre mondiale ou par les Allemands et
qui était sur des lunes et qui avec le
comment s'appelle je sais pas si on peut
parler de changement climatique mais
avec les tempêtes furieuses qu'on trouve
si vous voulez à l'estuaire de de
comment s'appelle du bassin d'Arcachon
sur le banc d'Arguin en face de la dune
du Pilat et donc d'ailleurs pour
qui est un très beau site ciblé ou je
sais pas moi je suis tout à l'heure ce
qu'on disait avec Jean-Pierre voilà je
suis dans ce site je sais pas ça me
parle j'ai envie de fixer sur sur
numérique moi je travaille en Amérique
bon en 2000 en 2000 si vous voulez
l'argentique vous êtes un comment dire
moïcon le dernier des Mohicans avec
l'argentique
les jeunes actuellement s'intéressent de
plus en plus à l'argent
le numérique comme vous le disiez c'est
pas ça suffit pas de prendre une photo
ça se donc moi quand je fais une photo
une photo c'est une photographe
comme disait quartier Bresson
photographié c'est voir ce que les
autres ne voient pas absolument je crois
que c'est une très belle je crois que
c'est très magnifique définition
photos mais tout le monde n'est pas
photographe
vous allez peut-être trouver que je suis
un peu sévère mais pour moi il y a des
gens qui font des images il y a des gens
qui font de la photo voilà après on peut
tout à fait faire des images qu'on
s'amuser mais bon voilà c'est moi je
trouve que c'est que c'est pas mal si
vous voulez de dire ça quoi donc mais je
ne j'aime beaucoup cette région mais je
m'intéresse aussi à d'autres sujets donc
je viendrez faire des chroniques
régulières sur la sur la photo
j'ai quelques amis quand même qui ont
qui sont des gens qui ont un certain
talent photographique comme Jean-Pierre
que j'ai voulu commencer par le un des
plus importants dans mes amis et après
pour qu'on puisse montrer aux gens
cibler le travail des gens et que on
puisse le partager
moi j'ai un site photo donc ça permet
d'aller voir ce que voilà on peut les
voir sur votre site
merci beaucoup à tous les deux donc je
rappelle du 28 février au 1er avril à
Épône à la médiathèque pierre Amouroux
et puis et puis Jean-Pierre on peut on
peut toujours aller à la galerie rouge
voilà
rue du pont Louis-Philippe à Paris c'est
ça merci merci infiniment merci à tous
merci à toi de nous avoir reçu Patrice
et puis bon continuation et vive la
photo
[Musique]